so if i were to give you the fraction 1
3 i could rewrite it if i multiply both
the numerator and the denominator by 2 1
times 2 is 2
and 3 times 2 is 6. so we know that 1 3
is the same thing as 2 6. this is true
the 1 3 is just another way of saying 2
6.
now given that we know that which of
these
i guess you could say picture equations
actually show us that that is true show
that to us visually and we could start
with this first one we have three equal
sections so each of these sections are a
third and we have one of those thirds
shaded in
now if we go on the right side we have
six equal sections so they are it's
divided into sixths and we have two of
them shaded in
one
two
and the important thing to realize is is
over here we divided the same rectangle
to the thirds as we divide into sixths
over here we are comparing fractions of
the same hole and so you see that if you
were to take these two magenta boxes and
put them together they actually do have
the same area as this one larger this
one larger rectangle so this one looks
like a good a good picture explanation
or visual explanation for why 1 3 is
equal to 2 6. you take the same
rectangle divide it into thirds and take
one of them
and then you take that same exact
rectangle divide it into six and pick
two of them you have shaded in the same
amount 1 3 over here is the same thing
as 2 6
over here now the important thing to
realize is is that you're taking 1 3 and
2 6 of the exact same rectangle when you
look over at these figures you see that
this is one-third this is one-third of
this figure right over here it's split
into three equal sections and this is
one of them that's shaded in and then
this is
this is right over here two
six you have six equal sections and
we've shaded in two of them
but
and we know that one-third is equal to
2-6 but this picture isn't true this
shaded area right over here is less than
the shaded area over here so you're
saying wait why doesn't it work why
isn't this one third the same thing as 2
well because you're taking 2 6 of a
larger hexagon here here you're taking
one third of a smaller figure here
taking 2 6 of a larger figure you can't
compare fractions of different holes
this at 2 6 of a larger hole is going to
be larger than 1 3 of a smaller hole the
only time that 1 3 and 2 6 are going to
be equivalent is if they are of the same
hole like we saw up here so this is not
true
and so for the same reason this right
over here is one-third and this over
here is 2 6. this is one-third of a
smaller circle than this 2-6 is so this
is not true
and by that same logic we have these
other these other pictures over here and
over here we're not talking about 1 3
and 2 6. here we're talking about let's
see splitting something into 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8.
so we're talking about eighths and in
this case it's one two three four five
six
six eighths and we're comparing it let's
see over here they're dividing into 4
and they've shaded in 3.
now it is true that 6 8 is equal to 3 4.
6 divided by 2 is 3 8 divided by 2 is 4.
so if you divide if you multiply or
divide the numerator by the exact same
thing
then you're going to get an equivalent
fraction
now 6 8 is equal to 3 4
but this picture isn't true because 6 8
would be equal to 3 4 if you're talking
about taking 6 8 and 3 4 of the same
size in this case diamond these things
are not the same size so you can't make
this picture statement
same thing for this one over here these
circles are of different sizes so taking
taking the same fraction of different
sizes you can't say that they're going
to be equal
this last one you're taking the
fractions of the same hole it's kind of
this weird
our left pointing arrow looking shape
but they are the same shape and you see
here we've divided that shape into
eighths and we have shaded in six of
them one two let me do that in a yellow
so you can see it
one two three four five six
and over here we have divided it into
fourths
and we have shaded in three of them
and we have shaded into three of them
and so this statement is true we knew we
already knew that 6 8 and 3 4 are the
same thing but this this this picture
right over here visually shows us that
because we're taking 6 8 of the same
hole as we're taking three fourths of
and you see that here this area
this area that i'm let me shade in a
different color
so the area that i'm shading in
six of these
equally areaed or these triangles with
equal areas the same thing as
four oh as three of these parallelograms
or three of the four these have the same
area you could see that one of these
one of these
like that one right over there could be
equivalent to this
over here
equivalent to that
over there actually let me do that for
all of them
this one
over here
could be equivalent to
let's see if you were to flip it over it
would be equivalent to that over there
and then finally i think you see where
this is going
this one over here
is equivalent to
this one over here so we have the same
fraction shaded in we just divided the
one on the left into more equal pieces
than we did on the right but these are
equivalent fractions and this picture
shows us that 6 8 is indeed equal to 3
4. once again 6 8 of the same whole is
equal to 3 4 of that same hole